mes chers collègues je souhaite la
bienvenue aux membres de la commission
d'enquête pour ce qui s'annonce comme le
début d'une semaine un peu chargée nous
sions ce soir comme vous le savez mais
aussi toute la journée de de jeudi et
jeudi nous démarrons à 8h30 alors nous
commençons nos travaux avec
l'audition ouverte à la presse et
également diffuser sur nos réseaux des
représentants de dernière rénovation je
vous remercie d'avoir accepté notre
invitation je vous remercie d'autant
plus que nous avions à l'origine prévu
une table ronde mais
d'autres associations n'ont pas souhaité
venir échanger en tout en tous les cas
je me réjouis que nous puissions avoir
cette cet échange cet après-midi alors
madame messieurs vous savez que que des
scènes de violence aussi bien urbaines
que rural ont émaillé les manifestations
et les rassemblements qui a connu la
France au cours du printemps dernier
nous avons pour tâche à la fois
d'étudier les faits commis et
d'apprécier la réponse opérationnelle
donnée aussi bien par les autorités
administratives que judiciaire je
précise immédiatement que notre
commission d'enquête n'a aucun pouvoir
de décision
ni sociale ni environnementale et qu'il
ne nous appartiendra aucunement de
formuler un avis sur des sujets comme
réforme des retraites ou relance du
nucléaire c'est pas du tout l'objet de
notre de notre commission d'enquête
aussi si nous pouvons comprendre les
positions de principe et leur expression
je demanderai à chacun d'entre vous de
se concentrer évidemment sur nos sujets
c'est l'objectif d'une commission
d'enquête alors un questionnaire vous a
été transmis
par notre rapporteur monsieur Florent
Boudier un certain de questions pourront
être donner lieu à des réponses écrites
par par la suite et donc avant de vous
faire prêter serment et de passer la
parole aux rapporteur il me revient de
poser les deux premières questions qui
permettront d'introduire nos débats en
premier lieu vous représentez un
collectif qui ne commet pas de violence
je voudrais savoir si cette option a été
considérée ou discuté ou si elle s'est
imposée d'évidence en revanche dernière
rénovation procède fréquemment à des
actions qui peuvent tout de même être
pénalement répréhensible principalement
sur le terrain de ce que l'on peut
appeler l'entrave ou la dégradation de
bien public ou privée et donc là aussi
même question cet objet cette option
fait-elle l'objet de discussions
internes à votre mouvement en second
lieu je voudrais savoir comment dans les
manifestations vous réagissez lorsque
vous réalisez qu'un Black Bloc est en
train de se former à proximité est-ce
que cette situation
n'arrive pas
en raison de mesures d'anticipation de
votre part il y a-t-il une consigne
prétablie de reflux de rupture du
contact ou bien chacun est-il laissé
libre d'agir assaguise en fonction du
contexte voilà quelques quelques
éléments et donc pour pour cela et
conformément à la procédure je vais vous
demander madame messieurs avant de vous
donner la parole et en application de
l'article 6 de l'ordonnance numéro
58-1100 du 17 novembre 1958 relatives au
fonctionnement des assemblées
parlementaires de prêter serment de dire
la vérité toute la vérité rien que la
vérité et donc je vais vous demander de
à tour de rôle de
de d'appuyer sur sur le bouton pour vous
permettre de vous exprimer de lever la
main droite et de dire je le jure on va
le faire dans dans l'ordre donc tout
d'abord Madame Marchal je le jure je
vous remercie monsieur Taieb
et Monsieur
calta
merci beaucoup
pardon je vais déjà vous donner la
parole par rapport à ses premières
questions et puis ensuite on enchaînera
avec les questions de monsieur le
rapporteur puis celle des collègues et
donc j'invite aussi les collègues à ce
manifester auprès de moi pour m'indiquer
lorsqu'ils souhaiteront évidemment
intervenir donc je vous passe la parole
à vous de décider le l'ordre de
d'intervention donc on a compris qu'il
était d'usage de commencer par un propos
liminaire que je débute nous nous
présentons devant cette commission
d'enquête parlementaire pour répondre à
votre convocation pour audition quel est
le sens de cette convocation de notre
collectif dernière rénovation dans une
enquête sur je cite des groupuscules
auteurs de violence nous ne sommes pas
un groupuscule terme péjoratif d'emblée
et nous sommes fondamentalement non
violents la non-violence et notre ADN le
principe même de notre action alors quel
est le sens de notre présence ici notre
campagne revendique des mesures
législatives enfin des terminantes
contre l'évolution dramatique du climat
alors merci de nous donner cette
nouvelle occasion de porter notre
message auprès des institutions nous
avons déjà pu le faire dans une audition
au Sénat à propos de la politique du
gouvernement sur la rénovation thermique
des bâtiments et notre campagne a
contribué à l'avènement d'un vote
majoritaire sur cette question en
novembre dernier à l'Assemblée nationale
nous étions là pour défendre sa
légitimité
initialement vous l'avez dit monsieur le
Président la convocation de ce soir
correspondait à une table ronde
d'associations de défense de
l'environnement corrigeons tout de suite
nous ne sommes pas une association de
défense de l'environnement nous sommes
une campagne de résistance civile non
violente nous sommes des citoyennes et
des citoyens des gens ordinaires qui
résistent
à l'effondrement de notre société à
l'effondrement de nos conditions de vie
de notre sécurité vitale à toutes et
tous
nous sommes des personnes jeunes moins
jeunes dans toute la France animatrice
boulangère ingénieur fromager étudiant
charpentier
nous sommes des mers des pères des
frères et sœurs des grands-parents
qui s'engagent pour protéger les
personnes et le monde qu'ils aiment
des personnes comme nous il y en a
partout dans le monde dans chaque pays
il y a des poches de résistance des gens
qui se battent pour un monde vivable un
monde qui ne serait durerait pas à des
niches préservées pour les plus
privilégiés les plus puissants au milieu
d'un enfer ce ne sont pas des
convictions que je présente ce sont des
faits scientifiques ce ne sont pas nos
mots ce sont par exemple ceux du
Secrétaire général des Nations unies qui
dit nous sommes sur une autoroute vers
l'enfer climatique avec le pied sur
l'accélérateur dernière rénovation fait
partie d'un réseau présentant 11 pays
avec des personnes aussi déterminées que
nous qui s'organisent pour résister au
chaos
nous espérons de toutes nos forces que
partout dans le monde les populations
enjoignent les institutions de leur pays
à agir au plus vite
notre méthode a fait ses preuves dans
l'histoire
la résidence civile non violente le
droit de vote des femmes la
reconnaissance des droits des personnes
racisées les droits fondamentaux des
personnes atteintes du sida tout ça n'a
pas du tout été obtenu par le seul
fonctionnement parlementaire
ces victoires sont le fruit d'action
perturbatrices non violente menée par
des personnes courageuses et déterminées
comme eux nous créons des perturbations
non violentes et nous continuerons
jusqu'à obtenir les changements
indispensables à notre survie collective
déranger un peu le cours des choses
pour ne pas voir le cours des choses
nous mener en enfer c'est le GIAC qui
déclare
dans une large mesure la société civile
et la seule force motrice sur laquelle
on puisse compter pour pousser les
institutions à changer au rythme voulu
c'est pour ça qu'on est là
pour que nos actions produisent les
changements nécessaires pour nous
protéger nous et les générations à venir
parce que nous prenons nos
responsabilités en tant que citoyenne et
citoyens
on traite très concrète avec pour
premier pas l'application des mesures de
la convention citoyenne pour le climat
concernant la rénovation énergétique des
bâtiments il s'agit d'un plan à la
hauteur de l'urgence expertisé qui mise
sur la capacité des institutions à
respecter leur sens premier
œuvrer pour l'intérêt général
concrètement engager un tel plan de
rénovation constituerait un triple
bénéfice en diminuant la dépendance
énergétique de la France en réduisant
nos émissions de gaz à effet de serre et
enfin en permettant aux 12 millions de
personnes qui vivent dans la précarité
énergétique de s'en sortir car était
comme hiver cette forme de précarité tue
tous les ans par milliers dans la plus
grande indifférence
nous avons adressé un premier
ultimatum à l'Elysée en mars 2022
constatant l’inefficacité des politiques
publiques en la matière et nous n'avons
pas été entendus
en conséquence nous avons mené trois
vagues d'actions successives ces actions
avec d'autres ont replacé l'urgence
climatique dans le coeur du débat
mobiliser des centaines de personnes et
en novembre 2022 ça a été dit une hausse
considérable du budget à louer aux
politiques de rénovation a été votée au
sein de cette Assemblée
malgré cela le gouvernement a écarté ce
résultat par le 49-3 et s'est contenté
jusque là de très timide réformes
pour cette raison nous continuons nos
actions
et nous assumons nos responsabilités
face à l'Histoire là où ce même
gouvernement les esquives
car de façon générale l'action politique
est indigente l'État a été condamné par
les tribunaux administratifs pour le
manque d'efforts à faire baisser les
émissions de CO2 le secrétaire général
de l'ONU lui-même a qualifié de
pitoyable la réponse des états au
réchauffement climatique
cet indifférence pour nos vies ce choix
pour les profils immédiats représentent
aujourd'hui un crime de masse
si rien ne change il faut s'attendre au
pire chaque degré de réchauffement
global en plus implique une hausse de
plus de 10% des conflits armés la
trajectoire actuelle condamne des
régions où vivent des milliards d'êtres
humains à devenir inhabitable et aucun
d'entre nous ici ne sera épargné par un
tel chaos le déni ou le cynisme ne
protégera personne
et pourtant nous voici là aujourd'hui à
devoir entendre malheureusement des
suspicions d'une commission d'enquête
qui se trompe nous le pensons encore de
combat et de coupable
les plus grands scientifiques pointent
du doigt l'effondrement de nos
conditions d'existence pendant ce temps
certains députés pas tous heureusement
s'acharnent sur les citoyens qui
défendent la vie sans violence ils
prennent alors bien soin de ne pas
cibler les groupuscules d'extrême droite
qui sévissent par tabassage et
agressions dans le pays attisant la
haine quand on a plus que jamais besoin
de solidarité
les décisions de la classe politique
depuis des dizaines d'années nous ont
placé moi vous toutes les générations
actuelles dans ce que la justice appelle
un état de nécessité c'est l'état dans
lequel on se trouve face à un danger si
grand qu'on est obligé de transgresser
des lois pour y faire face
comme le dit le rapporteur spécial des
Nations Unies sur les défenseurs de
l'environnement et j'espère que vous
aurez l'honnêteté donc convenir
certaines actions illégales
sont parfois légitimes non seulement nos
actions sont légitimes mais les choix
politiques les ont rendus nécessaires
indispensables parce que tout ce qu'il y
avait avant comme recours pour se faire
entendre a été ignoré méprisé et par là
c'est notre droit à la vie qui a été
méprisé
les marches les rapports scientifiques
il faut que vous étiez le micro voilà il
y en a qu'un qui fonctionne à la fois
les marches les rapports scientifiques
les pétitions les recours en justice les
grèves lycéennes les alertes les mesures
internationales les rendez-vous de
plaidoyer les luttes locales les
discours à l'ONU n'ont pas été entendus
aujourd'hui nous sommes nous en sommes à
bloquer des routes pacifiquement amener
des actions coup de poing pacifiquement
à s'envoyer en garde à vue toujours
pacifiquement pour vous faire agir
j'aimerais que tout le monde se rende
compte de où est-ce qu'on en est arrivé
je ne sais pas quelles histoires soient
racontent les gens pouvoirs aujourd'hui
mais moi je vais vous dire ce que je
vois autour de moi dans la lutte je vois
d'autres jeunes qui comme moi sont
poussés vers le précipice ça tout le
monde le sait n'importe qui qui a eu un
rapport du GIEC le sait aujourd'hui
quand on a mon âge et qu'on garde la
réalité en face quand on fait soit là on
doit faire le deuil de ses projets de
vie on doit faire les deuil de ces
projets de famille
de son avenir imaginer un futur à plus
de 5 ou 10 ans n'a strictement aucun
sens aujourd'hui pour moi et pour tous
les jeunes comme moi
en face de nous il y a des gens souvent
plus âgés qui exigent que l'on se taise
au lieu de nous tendre la main pour
essayer de nous aider face à cette
catastrophe
j'espère que vous saisirez un jour si
c'est pas aujourd'hui l'aliénation que
ça représente
cette injonction au silence face à la
fin du monde telle qu'on le connaît je
crois que c'est quelque chose que
l'histoire retiendra comme profondément
obscène alors vous savez tout ça est
déjà tellement violent que les
intimidations peuvent plus tellement
attaquer notre détermination
malheureusement nos mouvements peuvent
être dissous on peut être stigmatisés on
peut être poursuivi on peut être mis en
garde à vue mis en prison on ne
s'arrêtera pas
les langues et le mouvement ne
s'arrêteront pas c'est le plus grand
défi de l'humanité qui nous demande
d'être à la hauteur et nous n'avons pas
d'autres choix la répression de notre
action est dérisoire face à ce qui nous
attend si on choisit de ne rien faire à
chaque fois que l'un de nous sera mis en
cellule tabassée intimidé vous verrez
que parmi nous parmi celles et ceux qui
descendent défendent la vie sur Terre
personne ne tremble
on fait face à une faire une peur qui
est infiniment plus grande j'espère que
chacun ici il comprend
et j'aimerais ajouter une dernière chose
qui est peut-être la chose la plus
importante dans ce qui doit être dit ici
dans cette commission spécifiquement qui
est aussi la raison pour laquelle une
campagne non violente est venue à cette
commission malgré l'intitulé qui a été
souligné par Florence
si la résistance civile non violente
d'aujourd'hui n'est pas entendu
inévitablement ce sont des générations
entières qui seront encore plus acculés
encore plus désespéré et ça vous le
savez mieux que nous c'est extrêmement
dangereux le réchauffement climatique ne
s'arrêtera pas par comme par magie vous
l'avez compris et par conséquent la
lutte ne s'arrêtera pas non plus la
répression n'y changera rien mais vous
êtes les personnes au pouvoir
aujourd'hui vous êtes les puissants dans
ce combat je sais que vous le savez ça
veut aussi dire que vous allez le
pouvoir de décider quelle forme va
prendre cette lutte
ça veut dire que sur les questions de
violence comme pour le reste la balle
est dans votre camp à vous ici
vous voulez vraiment préserver la
société des affrontements et de la
violence validez les méthodes non
violentes au lieu de les criminaliser et
donner des victoires politiques à la
résistance civile non violente toutes
les autres issues sont chaotiques
inévitablement et je vais conclure ce
propos liminaire avec une question pour
tous les gens qui s'y qui sont ici mais
aussi pour tous les gens qui nous
regardent peut-être selon vous qui va
protéger les populations y compris les
Françaises et les Français y compris nos
familles y compris vos familles à tout
ce qui est ici
qui va nous protéger face au ravage du
réchauffement climatique jusqu'à
maintenant le gouvernement ne le fait
pas c'est un fait reconnu judiciairement
c'est donc la responsabilité de chaque
personne chaque adulte de regarder la
réalité en face et d'agir ne jamais
cesser d'agir tant que le gouvernement
ne prend pas ses responsabilités merci
de nous avoir écoutés
très bien je vais tout d'abord passer
avant de vous repasser la parole je vais
passer la parole à Monsieur le
Rapporteur quelques instants oui merci
monsieur le Président Merci à VOUS
contrairement à d'autres structures
associatives ou pas associatif d'avoir
accepté le principe de cet échange dans
le cadre d'une commission d'enquête
vous interrogiez les membres de la
Commission bancaire Madame Marchal en
disant quel est le sens de cette
convocation
le préfet de police de Paris n'est pas
un groupuscule violent
les médias réseaux sociaux que nous
interrogerons dans quelques jours ne
sont pas des groupuscules violents une
professeure d'université que nous avons
interrogé il y a maintenant 15 jours ne
fait pas partie des groupuscules
violents et le journaliste Thierry
Vincent que nous allons interroger dans
quelques minutes après l'audition que
vous acceptez ici
d'Honoré n'est pas non plus membre d'un
groupe musculaire
et donc il n'y a aucune méprise à avoir
sur le sens de votre convocation
nous estimons par contre qu'il y a un
sujet
dans le cadre d'un salon de violence
commise à l'occasion d'un certain nombre
de rassemblement
un sujet de frontière entre violence et
violence il vient un certain nombre
d'organisation qui ont choisi l'action
violente il y a un certain nombre
d'individus qui n'appartiennent à aucune
organisation structurée qui ont décidé
le mode d'action de la radicalité
violente il y a un certain nombre
d'organisations vous en faites partie
qui ne souhaitent pas rentrer dans une
logique de radicalisation violente
notamment envers les personnes et qui au
contraire
s'affirme comme étant des organisations
non violente et donc c'est le cas pour
dernière rénovation c'est l'intérêt de
votre audition ici c'est le sens de la
convocation que nous avons adressé je
lis d'ailleurs aussi
aux côtés de monsieur le Président les
structures qui n'ont pas souhaité
répondre à une convocation à laquelle on
ne peut pas normalement dont on ne peut
pas se retirer
peut-être convocation est une invitation
mais c'est aussi une convocation à
laquelle on doit se présenter ces
structures nous irons chercher leur
présence parce qu'ils nous semble
intéressantes intéressantes qu'il puisse
ici nous donner quelques explications
vous dites conviction est fait
mais nous n'avons aucun doute sur vos
convictions et nous avons aucun doute
sur les faits que vous avez indiqué en
revanche le mode d'action
que vous choisissez le mode d'action que
choisissent d'autres individus d'autres
groupes ou d'autres groupements ça ça
relève de la conviction du mode d'action
Benjamin Lucas ici présent pardon de
citer mon collègue à choisir un mode
d'action qui s'appelle la représentation
nationale et il est député vous
choisissez un mode d'action qui est
celui de structure qui parfois prône la
désobéissance civile on pourra en parler
l'action non violente des déterminée on
pourra en parler mais ici ce qui va nous
intéresser je vous dis vraiment très
clairement
c'est pas l'ultra droite à l'occasion
des rassemblements parce que les
éléments qui nous sont communiqués
pardon monsieur le Président d'être
aussi long montre qu'elle n'a pas
participé directement à ce stade de nos
auditions aux violences que nous
étudions mais nous interrogeons
systématiquement aux interlocuteurs sur
la réalité des violences provenant de
l'ultra-droite dans les rassemblements
et les manifestations nous parlons et
nous avons les indications très claires
d'affrontement entre ultra gauche et
ultra droite dans certains cas donc
essayons d'avoir la réalité des faits de
façon objective
mais aujourd'hui nous souhaitons mieux
comprendre en tant que député de la
nation quelle est la frontière entre
violence et non violence comment
aujourd'hui elle se joue dans un centre
d'action qui sont de plus en plus
radical qui a les mêmes la notion de
radicalité qu'est-ce qu'elle veut dire à
vos yeux comment elle se légitime en
quoi la désobéissance est-elle civile ou
un civile voilà nous cherchons
simplement d'être nourri de la réflexion
par des acteurs qui nous semblent
légitimes d'interroger puisque nous
avons convié à venir devant cette
commission d'enquête
et juste pour poursuivre prolonger le
propos de Monsieur le rapporteur vous
voyez ce qui nous intéresse c'est que
comme vous avez pu l'indiquer vous avez
un choix qui est celui de la
non-violence
néanmoins tout en choisissant la
non-violence il vous arrive d'aller sur
le terrain de l'entrave d'ailleurs vous
vous le savez pertinemment quand
et vous le dites c'est un réseau
d'ailleurs qui qui est transnational
puisque sont des actions que l'on
retrouve à d'autres endroits en
Allemagne etc et sur le terrain de
l'entrave et bien comment dire ce qui
nous intéresse c'est qu'est-ce qui qui
vous amène à justifier cela puisque en
fait dans les éléments d'entrave et bien
on est sur quelque chose d'illégal alors
bien entendu je suis taillé quand vous
disiez il y a des choses qui peuvent
être illégales mais légitimes mais
malgré tout quand on est sur quelque
chose illégal c'est quelque chose
d'illégal et je dirais que à un moment
donné il y a une frontière du ralex
c'est de l'ex quoi et donc un moment
donné lorsque l'on décide de ne pas
respecter la loi la question est de
savoir ce qui peut légitimer justement
alors vous parlez d'état de nécessité
sont des éléments qui effectivement
méritent que que l'on puisse avoir votre
éclairage sur sur ces points là je vais
vous repasser la parole et puis on
pourra évidemment échanger
pardon de revenir sur ce préalable
de pas de méprise vous pouvez pas quand
même faire abstraction du fait que nous
nous présentons dans un contexte de
répression historique inégalée de
mouvement citoyens de de
citoyens engagés et que on assiste à des
dissolutions de de mouvement qui sont
soutenus par des centaines de millions
de personnes on assiste à des
répressions judiciaires si on parle pour
dernière rénovation qui sont non
proportionnées par rapport à
aux entraves dont vous parlez aux délit
et c'est pas moi qui le dis ce sont des
rapports des Nations Unies donc permet
de nous quand même de replacer cette
venue de notre collectif dans un
contexte où effectivement
nos
collectifs de citoyens engagés pour
essayer de préserver le bien commun sans
très menacés actuellement
par le pouvoir exécutif donc c'est quand
même le contexte c'est la réalité
oui moi je voulais juste compléter sur
parce que effectivement les actions sont
des actions de désobéissance civile qui
sont assumées à visage découvert toutes
et transparent tous les gens qui ont
fait des actions avec dernier rénovation
sont à visage découvert ils ont donc
tous ou pour l'extrême majorité assumer
leurs actes devant la justice certains
ont
eu la faveur d'une dispense de peine
d'autres ont été condamnés en première
instance et on fait appel
mais je pense que la fin j'aimerais
quand même recadrer le débat sur juste
un point si on se pose la question de la
violence et qu'est-ce qui nous est sur
quel chemin on est actuellement et je
pense qu'on est sur le chemin pour
garder historiquement entre les mois je
vous interrompre s'il y a quelqu'un qui
recadre les débats c'est moi non bien
sûr voilà
un moment donné soyons quand même dans
une logique encore une fois on est là
pour vous entendre mais attention aux
mots que vous employés voilà je vais
dire donc s'il faut les recadrer je les
recadrer
j'essaie de vous faire une réponse
sincèrement si elle vous si vous pensez
que c'est à côté je repréciserai avec
plaisir
moi ma question c'est qu'est-ce qui nous
reste d'autres aujourd'hui vous posez la
question de comment ça se fait
qu'aujourd'hui des jeunes et des moins
jeunes à en arrivent à Florence et
médecins on arrive à bloquer la route à
faire en travers la circulation et
assumer les conséquences de leurs actes
ça veut dire aller en garde à vue on a
tous été ici en garde à vue on n'ira peu
probablement tous en procès donc qui
pourquoi on en arrive là parce que il
faut quand même remettre une perspective
historique de tous les autres moyens ont
été utilisés je personne ne fait ça par
plaisir il faut que vous en ayez
vraiment conscience personne ne fait ça
par plaisir les premières impactés c'est
nous et du coup Nicolas Hulot qui
démissionne parce qu'il dit qu'il n'y a
aucun moyen d'action les marches par
millions les actions en justice qui
aboutissent qui sont victorieuses et qui
ne changent rien en fait on essaye juste
d'être lucide politiquement et là
aujourd'hui on estime que la lutte la
désobéissance civile et la résistance
civile non violente comme elle a été
pratiquée dans l'histoire avec les
suffragettes avec les mouvements pour
les droits civils américains et en
France plus récemment avec les droits et
la lutte contre le sida les droits pour
les personnes homosexuelles et la lutte
contre le sida aujourd'hui on estime que
c'est la meilleure option pour nous et à
raison
et j'espère qu'aujourd'hui ça le restera
et pour moi c'est votre rôle
d'institution que de montrer que c'est
un méthode d'action qui est valide qui
est légitimée parce que sinon
effectivement il y a des problèmes de
dérive de gens
de comprendre moi ce qui m'intéresse on
peut en tant que rapporteur qui va
écrire un rapport bon c'est c'est de
mesurer et je n'ai pas d'idées
préconçues sur le sujet ce qui relève de
l'incitation à la violence de
provocation à la violence et je fais une
distinction dans la gradation en tout
cas je pense qu'ici tous les collègues
présents font une distinction entre
l'entrave sur une autoroute
éventuellement enfin je pense cet
exemple mais il y a d'autres qui est un
mode d'ailleurs relativement ancien
parce que j'ai le souvenir entre en tant
que militant d'un ancien parti politique
de leur participer à une entrave
routière cette route nationale c'était
pas une autoroute bon voilà donc je fais
des aveux moi aussi de d'action passé
mais je fais la distinction entre
l'entrave je fais la distinction entre
certains phénomènes qui peuvent avoir
une gravité ou qui sont des infractions
pénales et puis on voit bien le passage
à la violence aux personnes
la dégradation systématique qui n'est
pas simplement à qui est le sabotage la
destruction qui peut aller beaucoup plus
loin et qui fait que il y a aujourd'hui
une frontière qui semble plus
troubles entre ce qui relève du
militantisme de l'activisme et ce qui
relève de la violence nous on parle bien
des groupuscules violents ceux qui
s'attaquent par conséquent au bien mais
aussi aux personnes qui est un choix que
vous n'avez pas fait et donc ce qui nous
intéresse je pense c'est
je comprends bien le passage de
frontières que vous indiquez moi ce que
j'entends sera ma question
j'entends beaucoup dire y compris de la
part d'un syndrome de militants une fois
que la voix judiciaire a été perdu une
fois que la voie électorale était perdue
j'en viens à la violence parce que c'est
mon seul modèle d'action est-ce que
c'est quelque chose que vous partagez ou
est-ce que vous êtes aujourd'hui plutôt
des régulateurs d'expression de cette
violence avant qu'elle ne se commette ou
est-ce que vous pensez que votre
résonance au raisonnement pardon est une
pierre dans une succession d'événements
qui peut aboutir à la violence je pose
ces questions avec non pas naïveté bien
sûr mais un vrai intérêt parce que cette
frontière aujourd'hui elle me semble
floue et elle me semble parfois aussi
instrumentalisée
merci merci pour pour votre question
déjà vous avez dit vous avez parlé de
violence par rapport à des attentes ou
bien en droit pénal français il y a une
distinction quand même entre la
dégradation et la violence qui est peu
exclusivement tourné vers les personnes
donc on parle de violence normalement
quand on s'en prend aux personnes et ça
nous en aucun cas on va on va légitimer
ça d'une façon ou d'une autre
[Musique]
maintenant il y a effectivement il y a
toute une nuance et c'est légitime de
s'interroger sur face à une certaine
situation mais une situation d'urgence
une situation de crise une situation où
les institutions peuvent être bloquées
peuvent être dans une incapacité à
protéger le bien commun et à répondre à
cette intérêt général pour lesquels les
représentants du peuple sont élus il y a
une légitimité c'est à dire maintenant
qu'est-ce qu'on fait effectivement nous
on se pose cette question ça veut pas
dire que une fois qu'on commence à se
poser la question tout est permis on
fait n'importe quoi ça veut dire que
enfin c'est pas c'est pas parce qu'on
sort du cadre de la légalité qu'on sort
du cadre de la morale et de l'éthique au
contraire on ira rentre d'autant plus
puisque on vient on vient s'interroger
vraiment sur ce qui est juste et pas
seulement sur ce qui légal ce que j'ai
le droit de faire ce que j'ai pas le
droit de faire donc nous des
organisations comme la nôtre bien sûr on
se pose cette question en profondeur et
on se pose des limites des limites
éthiques des limites morales qui sont
très claires et donc c'est la raison
pour laquelle c'est une des raisons pour
laquelle nous utilisons des techniques
des tactiques d'action qui sont non
violentes mais comme la rappeler pierre
tout à l'heure le risque c'est quoi face
à un réchauffement qui augmente de plus
en plus face à une tension sociale qui
est plus importante sur divers sujets
mais sur celui-ci notamment face à un
désespoir de plus en plus fort chez des
jeunes qui se sentent des jeunes des
moins jeunes qui se sentent impuissants
face à une situation qui menace leur vie
la vie de leurs proches bah écoutez
c'est c'est je dis pas que c'est
légitime mais je dis que c'est dans
l'ordre c'est dans une certaine logique
à ce que les actions de contestation se
radicalisent et deviennent de plus en
plus violentes et nous très clairement
c'est parce qu'on souhaite nous ce qu'on
souhaite c'est que grâce à des grâce à
nos actions on puisse enclencher des
changements de société d'ampleur qui
nous permettent de maintenir de nous
maintenir dans une société qui respecte
les limites planétaires c'est tout
est-ce que on peut on peut revenir aussi
sur sur la question de tout à l'heure
dans le dans la question que je posais
il y avait il y avait cette question du
rapport au Black Bloc donc vous vous
êtes présent dans un certain nombre de
manifestations quel est le
est-ce que votre organisation dernière
innovation donne des consignes en la
matière et puisque en réalité on voit
bien que les Black Blocs ont comme comme
moteur un moment donné de de
passer à de la violence
peut-être reclarifier rapidement les
actions de dernière rénovation parce que
du coup nos actions ont été
principalement jusque là des blocages de
route sur des petits groupes de
personnes du périphérique parisien et
d'autres routes sur le territoire
français qui ont été faits où il n'y a
même pas eu de réponse verbale même pas
de violence verbale envers qui que ce
soit physique encore moins donc on n'a
pas été en contact avec les Black Blocs
en réalité c'est pas une on n'a pas été
en contact parce que c'est pas notre
mode d'action notre mode d'action il est
perturbateur il n'est plus dans la
protestation il est dans la perturbation
pour essayer de créer un électrochoc
dans cette société
donc en tant qu'organisation dernière
rénovation vous ne participez pas
manifestations par exemple nous avons
quand on regarde un petit peu les
évidemment les manifestations auxquelles
on s'intéresse il y a notamment celles
autour de sainte Soline votre
organisation n'était pas présente non
nous n'avons pas appelé à participer à
aux manifestations de Sainte-Souline
pardon pour les collègues j'essaie
d'alimenter mon futur travail quand même
de rédaction
je reviens sur cette question de la
transition entre non violence et
violence je pose la question franchement
est-ce que
l'expression que vous avez vu à
l'instant en disant mais dépasser une
certaine limite tout autant en fixant
j'ai bien compris dépassé une certaine
limite ça c'est légitimité est-ce que
vous ne pensez pas première question que
ça peut être perçu par un certain nombre
de nos concitoyens comme une possibilité
d'aller encore plus loin et d'aller vers
une radicalisation violente y compris
vis-à-vis des personnes une première
question et deuxièmement est-ce que vous
pensez que vous pensez pas que ça
construit une sorte de face à face
binaire
qui dessert peut-être
la cause que vous vous conduisez une
question que je me pose deux questions
que je me pose en tout cas
je sais pas comment
vous dire à quel point votre question
elle a une focalisation
sur voilà c'est comme si c'était un bout
de leur niet
on parlait de Sainte-Souline
et des affrontements mais il y avait des
dizaines de milliers de personnes
qui venaient
plusieurs fois condamnés déjà moi je
trouve que la violence elle est celle
que vous celle que vous citez elle
m'effraie bien sûr
mais c'est pas c'est pas c'est là que je
vois tout le temps je trouve qu'il y a
un projecteur qui est disproportionné
sur la violence dont vous parlez et qui
nous fait peur à tous mais par contre on
ne parle pas de la violence de ce qui va
arriver dans nos vies
à mes enfants à moi-même je viens
d'avoir une petite fille avec un huit
mois que je viens de quitter tout à
l'heure on parle de cette violence là et
vous parlez de la voilà vous nous vous
nous concentrez sur à quel moment une
action de militantisme jusqu'au va et
vous vous ditiez un petit peu sur les
blocages c'est quand même une entrave
c'est quand même un délit donc c'est
normal que vous alliez en justice je
voudrais vous lire un extrait
d'un rapport des Nations Unies du 15
juin dernier
moi je précise juste un point c'est un
rapport d'expert des Nations Unies et
c'est un rapport qui ne porte pas
officiellement le logo des Nations Unies
l'institution nation unie parce que en
fait on a eu un débat déjà sur ce point
l'institution nation unie ne cautionne
pas ce rapport que les choses soient
quand même précises à cet égard c'est le
Rapporteur spécial sur les droits à la
liberté de réunion pacifique à la
liberté d'associations
qui dépend des Nations Unies
pardon de l'imprécision mais ce
rapporteur
[Musique]
jusque le droit de réunion pacifique est
un droit fondamental qui forme le socle
le même des systèmes de gouvernance
participative fondée sur la démocratie
les droits humains l'État de droit et le
plus réaliste
et ce rapport rappelle à la France que
toute stratégie de maintien de l'ordre
doit respecter les principes de
nécessité et de proportionnalité dans le
seul but de faciliter les réunions
Pacifique et de protéger les droits
fondamentaux des personnes qui
participent donc voilà moi la violence
je la vois aussi de façon très
importante sur
les réunions pacifiques et tous ces gens
qui auxquels je m'identifie qui qui se
font arrêter parce que j'en fais partie
de façon disproportionnée par rapport à
des actes qui sont certes répréhensibles
mais qui ne justifie pas toutes ces
répressions aux yeux des observateurs
internationaux
moi j'entends aussi de comment on arrête
comment on répond et comment on évite la
dérive violente et la tension dans la
société et je pense vraiment je
réinsiste sur le fait que là j'ai
l'impression que le pouvoir en place je
sais pas si vous personnellement mais le
pouvoir en place a choisi la voix de la
répression et je sais pas comment dire à
quel point c'est ne pas comprendre la
détresse dans laquelle on est
aujourd'hui face au réchauffement
climatique je pense vraiment que c'est
une c'est de la vraiment
l'incompréhension profonde de ce que
c'est que d'être jeune à cet âge-là et
de ne pas pouvoir se projeter et ça ne
va pas s'arrêter ça va être de pire en
pire cet été je sais pas combien de
morts on va devoir compter encore rien
qu'en France et je pense qu'il y a une
autre issue vraiment que vous devriez
considérer et que toutes les personnes
qui sont en charge aujourd'hui doivent
considérer c'est l'action politique
aujourd'hui le meilleur moyen de
pacifier l'action militante c'est de
donner des victoires politiques aux
méthodes non violentes si on ajoute à la
liste de la honte que j'ai cité tout à
l'heure des manifestations des rapports
en justice et tout ça la résistance
civile non violente qu'est-ce qui nous
restera pour les gens qui de toute façon
devront agir parce qu'il s'agira de vie
ou de mort et sur ça je vous invite à
vous renseigner sur les gens qui sont
beaucoup plus en détresse que nous
aujourd'hui dans les pays du Sud quel
choix ils font et c'est jamais
l'inaction jamais et je pense que c'est
vraiment une option qui doit être
considérée de manière un peu plus
sérieuse que actuellement
alors juste un point de précision nous
notre ça a été rappelé tout à l'heure
par monsieur le rapporteur une
commission d'enquête nous on est dans on
est au Parlement c'est-à-dire que on
considère justement qu'il y a une
séparation entre d'une part le
législatif d'autre part l'exécutif et
puis par ailleurs le judiciaire et ça
semble d'ailleurs un principe même donc
de du fonctionnement d'une institution
justement démocratique alors il y avait
d'autres demandes de prise de parole
donc monsieur Caron je vous en prie et
ensuite madame Diaz
merci monsieur le président
ma prise de parole sera d'abord pour
exprimer un étonnement
je trouve le cette audition un peu
surprenante
pour le moins pour l'instant
d'abord par la présence même devant nous
de porte-parole ou de militants ou de
membres de dernière rénovation qui sont
un mouvement ils l'ont rappelé qui
revendiquent la non-violence comme moyen
d'action or si je reprends l'intitulé
mais ça a été souligné mais je veux y
revenir parce que vraiment je suis
surpris nous devons bien enquêter sur la
structuration le financement les moyens
les modalités d'action des groupuscules
auteur de violence ou alors c'est à
supputer que dernière rénovation aurait
commis des violences
argumenter de mon étonnement j'ai bien
compris que vous ne les accusiez pas de
violence mais que vous vouliez en
connaître davantage sur par exemple leur
motivation
ça fait pas partie de l'intitulé de
notre commission d'enquête on n'est pas
là pour interroger gens sur leur
motivation mais sur la structuration au
financement les moyens les modélisations
des violents alors là vous avez une
autre question et c'est là que je suis
extrêmement surpris c'est on va essayer
de démontrer si quand même leur
existence ne poserait pas de problème à
notre démocratie est-ce que vous ne
pensez pas que bien qui est en non
violent le simple fait que vous
exprimiez ça ne pourrait pas encourager
à terme la violence et je dois avouer
que je ne comprends pas très bien votre
démarche si ce n'est peut-être avoir un
questionnement orienté pour détourner
l'objet même de cette commission
d'enquête la même manière monsieur le
rapporteur ou non c'est vous monsieur le
Président qui qui avait tenu à souligner
le fait que néanmoins quand même nous
avions devant nous des personnes qui
appartenaient un mouvement qui faisait
des choses illégales et la loi c'est la
loi vous avez tenu à le dire
et là je suis ennuyé parce que lors du
lancement cette commission d'enquête
vous avez rappelé que lorsque nous
auditionnons des personnes nous sommes
soumis à l'article 40 du code de posture
procédure pénal qui nous oblige à
rapporter éventuellement un fait légal
un crime un délit etc donc je comprends
pas très bien cette cette ambiguïté j'ai
presque l'impression que vraiment mais
c'est peut-être pas de votre fête et
c'est je ne vous prête aucune intention
je ne prête aucune intention mais ça
peut être inconscient parfois vous savez
l'inconscient qui s'exprime une certaine
manière pas chez vous il n'y a pas
d'inconscient chez vous vous feriez bien
exception à l'humanité
et je suis sûr qu'on ne faites pas
exception et donc tu vas peut-être comme
une forme de procès presque pour essayer
dans le questionnement qui est note pour
l'instant aujourd'hui c'est un petit peu
le commentaire donc je vous avouerai que
je ne comprends pas très bien ce que
nous sommes en train de faire en ce
moment même
vous avez raison c'était pas une
question mais vu que nous sommes dans
une commission d'enquête je crois qu'un
point de vue peut aussi être audible
très bien mesdames Diaz ensuite monsieur
Lucas puis monsieur tavernes et puis on
poursuivre
je vous en prie merci le président
bonjour madame bonjour messieurs vous
vous êtes décrit comme étant des
militants engagés
respectueux d'un mode d'action non
violent permettez-moi de vous dire que
je ne partage pas tout à fait votre
point de vue
tout d'abord je voudrais souligner la
dureté de l'intonation de vos propos
liminaires ensuite
je voudrais aussi souligner la dureté de
vos modes d'action vous dites qu'ils
sont nos violents mais quand vous
participez au blocage d'un périple ou
alors que vous faites intrusion dans des
dans des événements sportifs vous faites
preuve d'une certaine forme de violence
parce que vous imposez votre présence à
des personnes qui ne sont pas venues
pour vous regarder et enfin je voudrais
aussi souligner la dureté de vos propos
voire de vos accusations en tout cas du
champ lexical que vous employez vous
parlez d'offensive autoritaire vous
parlez de militants tabassés de crimin
de l'opposition vous parlez de mode
d'opération d'intimidation et de
répression moi la question que j'ai
envie de vous poser la première c'est
qu'est-ce qui vous permet de dire que
vos revendications sont plus légitimes
que d'autres qu'est-ce qui vous permet
de vous autoproclamer dans le camp du
Bien et qu'est-ce qui vous permet
d'affirmer que tous ceux qui ne pensent
pas comme vous seraient dans le déni et
n'aurait pas conscience du danger
criminel du danger de mort qui nous
attend tous donc je trouve que voilà
votre votre positionnement un peu
radical et pour le moins sectaire et ma
deuxième question c'est quelque part en
délégitimant ou en accusant la police
l'état tout ce qui représente les
institutions est-ce que vous ne
contribuez pas précisément à l'escalade
de la violence dont c'est le dont
l'objet dans c'est l'objet précisément
de notre commission d'enquête
parlementaire
oui je vous en prie
je vous remercie pour votre question
alors déjà vous avez expliqué que nos
actions entreraient peut-être dans comme
une certaine forme de violence moi je
sais pas ce que c'est une certaine forme
de violence le droit pénal est très
clair les violences sont qualifiées de
violence lorsque il y a des violences à
l'égard de personnes pas en contre-in
pas à les garder bien et à aucun moment
aucun ministère public n'a requis la
qualification de violence à l'encontre
de nos actions scénariste c'est vraiment
arrivé aucun moment donc j'insiste
vraiment là dessus moi je sais pas ce
que c'est une certaine forme de violence
mais nous on a ni un juge ni un
ministère public n'a jamais requis cette
qualification là donc c'est pour moi
c'est nul et non avenue ensuite sur le
camp vous dites qu'est-ce qui
justifierait que nous nous proclamions
dans le camp du Bien alors ça c'est une
vraie question une question une question
intéressante parce qu'effectivement dans
l'absolu avec un état d'esprit très
relativiste on pourrait se dire mais
après tout si vous faites des actions
illégales pour ce que vous défendez
pourquoi une autre d'autres groupes qui
viendraient défendre d'autres choses
complètement différentes pourraient pas
aussi promouvoir des actions illégales
mais nous soyons très clairs sur quoi on
se fonde on se fonde sur un consensus
scientifique un consensus scientifique
c'est quoi un consensus scientifique
c'est simplement la meilleure méthode la
meilleure manière d'obtenir et de
d'obtenir des connaissances alors
d'aujourd'hui donc il y a pas d'autres
de meilleurs moyens de savoir ce qui est
à peu près vrai que un consensus
scientifique et bien sûr en tant qu'être
humain on nage dans l'incertitude le
doute les opinions les convictions
diverses mais fondamentalement le
consensus scientifique c'est la chose la
plus solide dont nous disposons pour
justement avoir un minimum de certitudes
et avancer dans la bonne direction donc
nous nous sommes pas dans le camp du
Bien on se prétend pas dans le conduire
on dit juste attendez il y a un
consensus scientifique très clair qui
dit que des pays vont devenir
inhabitable à horizon 10 20 30 ans des
pays qui vont devenir inhabitables des
milliards de personnes qui vont être sur
les routes
donc on a des coins consensus
scientifiques qui nous dit que nous
notre biodiversité notre agriculture est
menacée en France à cause de ce
réchauffement climatique nos conditions
d'existence sont menacées à cause de ça
donc c'est pas une histoire d'être dans
le camp du bien ou pas c'est simplement
se dire mais au fait au fond comment
est-ce que je sais ce qui est vrai ce
qui est juste nous nous appuyons sur un
consensus scientifique voilà c'est tout
ensuite sur votre deuxième question
est-ce que nos actions contribuent à
l'escalade de la violence là on l'a
encore on a déjà un petit peu répondu à
ça et ça nous a été redemandés mais non
ce qui contribue à l'escalade de la
violence c'est l'indifférence des
pouvoirs publics c'est le c'est ce qui
contribue à l'escalade de la violence
c'est les élites économiques qui
refusent de prendre les mesures qu'il
faut pour restreindre
restreindre la folie dans laquelle du
système économique dans laquelle nous
sommes c'est
l'escalade de la violence c'est
l'impuissance ce sentiment d'impuissance
en fait qui est créé par tous ces jeunes
dont par les Pier res auparavant qui en
fait n'ont plus aucun moyen de défendre
leur vie et leur avenir
oui je vous en prie il faut juste voilà
on est légitime les institutions mais
pas du tout pas du tout puisque notre
objectif est d'obtenir des mesures
législatives et que on l'a dit dans le
préambule on est en contact on essaye de
faire en sorte que l'Assemblée nationale
le Sénat puisse
produire des lois qui vont dans le sens
de mesures réellement efficaces et notre
revendication principale unique c'est la
rénovation thermique des bâtiments et
pour ça on n'est pas du tout dans la
déligibilité des institutions sinon on
ne serait pas là aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup monsieur Lucas
je vous en prie merci monsieur le
Président je veux pas commencer par une
polémique inutile avec l'oratrice du
Front national si ce n'est dire que moi
je n'ai pas entendu une une parole j'ai
pas plus votre expression chers
collègues un champ lexical violent j'ai
au contraire entendu une parole que
j'estime lucide sincère et déterminé et
qui
montre que nous avons en face de nous
des gens qui veulent peser sur le cadre
du débat démocratique pour que nous
prenions un certain nombre de mesures
nécessaires et par remettre en cause
notre modèle démocratique je crois que
c'est important préalable que ce soit
dit et entendu et de ce point de vue là
je rejoins l'interrogation de mon
collègue sur le la pertinence de vous
entendre mais comme ce que vous nous
avez donné à entendre moi me paraît
extrêmement utile et nécessaire de ce
fait je me réjouis que que vous ayez été
convoqué je me permets un petit
préalable parce que le rapporteur m'a
cité énormément tout à l'heure pour
faire état de mon exemple personnel
chers collègues pour être député je n'en
suis pas moins militant et je sais comme
parlementaire et comme parlementaire
écologique écologiste singulièrement ce
que nous devons dans cette institution
dans l'histoire de notre République au
mouvement social au mouvement civique au
Mouvement Républicain ce que nous devons
notamment dans la période dans laquelle
nous sommes sur la question climatique
sur la question de la préservation de la
biodiversité on ne vaincra pas le plus
grand péril de l'histoire de l'humanité
qui est le périple climatique sans une
mobilisation de la société et donc sans
des citoyens et des citoyens conscients
mobiliser les terminer parfois beaucoup
plus lucide et beaucoup plus déterminée
que nous ne le sommes dans ces enceintes
et parce que nous avons à faire ça a été
dit à des forces à des forces
économiques à des forces d'inertie à des
lobbies puissants qui nécessitent que
nous parlementaires quand bien même nous
serions unanime à prendre les bonnes
décisions au royaume besoin d'un
mouvement dans la société et c'est ainsi
que ça se passe depuis deux siècles de
de République et je tiens aussi la le
dire il y a pas d'opposition de mon
point de vue entre l'engagement
parlementaire je sais que vous vous avez
d'abord bloqué des routes plus être
devenu parlementaires je considère que
il y a des choses qui a mal tourné chez
vous on peut continuer on peut continuer
à faire les deux évidemment non mais
j'espère pour vous mais voilà je pense
qu'on a on a besoin aussi de cette
conjonction qui est incarnée là et que
parfois oui la désobéissance parfois
l'action à l'égard de la loi d'un moment
s'avère à l'échelle de l'histoire et
vous avez placé la perspectiviste
historique dans votre propos s'avère
nécessaire et nous sommes dans toutes
nos familles politiques d'ailleurs les
héritières et les héritiers souvent de
personnes de militantes et de militants
qui ont lutté parfois aux marges de la
loi pour obtenir des grandes avancées
pour toutes et pour tous ma question
elle sera double elle sera d'abord sur
le maintien de l'ordre est-ce que vous
estimez que dans les actions qui sont
les vôtres le maintien de l'ordre tel
qu'il est organisé et de nature à
engager des des escalades et de
l'apaisement ou est-ce qu'il est
construit de nature ou est-ce qu'il a
amen à ce qu'il y ait parfois des
risques de tension qui monte
dans dans les actions qui sont les
vôtres et qui sont je le rappelle par
non violente mais est-ce que le maintien
de l'ordre tel qu'il est organisé et
nature j'allais dire à vous pour vous à
créer de l'apaisement et à ce qu'on
passe à autre chose ou est-ce qu'il met
de l'attention et enfin peut-être une
question sur le contexte dans lequel
nous sommes et qui va avec l'objet de
cette commission d'enquête est-ce que le
mouvement actuel de d'ultra répression
des organisations écologistes des
mouvements écologistes et nature à à
vous effrayer et à vous faire changer de
modalités d'action ou de ou de
détermination ou au contraire qui n'a
aucun impact et ce qui démontrerait le
cas échéant que on peut brutaliser un
mouvement n'empêche pas
je vous laisse répondre aux questions
posées par Monsieur Lucas merci
concernant le maintien de l'ordre je
pense que c'est spécifique à chaque
action et qu'il y a plein d'exemples et
tout est quasiment toutes nos actions
sont documentées donc on peut avoir des
exemples diverses et variés sur internet
donc je pense que là dessus les gens
peuvent se faire une idée moi ce que
j'ai vu par contre beaucoup c'est des
abus très clairs de l'intimidation très
claire à plusieurs égards on a failli
d'ailleurs pas pouvoir rentrer dans
cette assemblée parce que on a fait un
rassemblement de soutien devant et qui
bloquait l'accès ce qui aurait été une
ironie quand même pas mal et je pense
que c'est symptomatique de certaines
choses dans le pays et plus globalement
sur le maintien de l'ordre et on n'est
pas que dernier rénovation c'est un
mouvement plus global et vous le savez
et là pour le coup on a énormément
d'exemples de
d'abus clairement à tous les niveaux
concernant la deuxième question que je
veux bien que vous me rappeliez s'il
vous plaît parce que j'ai pas eu le
temps de la noter
de répondre un peu déjà à cette question
mais je vais peut-être développer un
tout petit peu sur la répression juste
un point puisque vous vous évoquez le
fait vous évoquez des abus et donc
est-ce que vous pourriez développer
qu'est-ce que vous entendez par abus
justement c'est je pourrais vous donner
beaucoup d'exemples mais je peux vous
donner un exemple par exemple quand on
est venu essayer de défendre à la devant
l'Assemblée nationale
du coup il est en novembre dernier le
vote qui avait été fait par les députés
donc les représentants de la nation dans
cette hémicycle on a eu par exemple une
policière qui nous disait qu'il y avait
pas besoin de faire de sommation
puisqu'on savait très bien que ce qui
était fait ce que ce que l'on faisait
était illégal il y a eu plusieurs
tentatives d'intimidation pour des
choses qu'on faisait était légal se
rassembler tout à l'heure et venir se
présenter à cette commission sans avoir
à passer par lui rues différentes et de
voir négocier avec un policier pour
pouvoir se présenter à une commission
parlementaire ça me semble être de
l'abus et il y en a de très nombreuses
autres moi par exemple j'étais sur
l'action des Champs-Élysées pour
laquelle j'étais en garde à vue on m'a
menacé de me casser le bras parce que je
enfin pour absolument aucune raison
simplement parce que je faisais une
action non violente c'est parmi les très
très nombreux exemples j'ai vu aussi
beaucoup de choses en garde à vue on
pourra témoigner plus longtemps je pense
et sur la question de la répression du
coup je pense avoir dit très clairement
que ça ne fera pas baisser la
détermination en tout cas pas au niveau
d'un mouvement moi ce que je sens et ce
que je vois c'est que au contraire ça
suscite une révolte encore plus grande
parce que ça vient rendre visible une
injustice qui était jusque là invisible
l'injustice qui est de se dire on
pourrait croire aujourd'hui et je sens
beaucoup de décontractions dans la salle
malgré les propos très lourds qu'on a de
l'injustice énorme qui est l'injustice
du réchauffement climatique c'est une
injustice géographique c'est une
injustice en fonction des âges et je
trouve que ça vient rendre visible
simplement une violence qui était déjà
présente je pense pas que la répression
aujourd'hui parce qu'en fait qu'est-ce
que c'est quoi les autres issues
possibles soit le réchauffement
climatique s'arrête et dans ce cas là on
a plus de raison de se mobiliser mais
c'est pas parti pour avec l'action
politique qui est en cours soit on
décide tout d'un coup de ne plus avoir
envie de vivre et de se résigner mais je
ne pense pas que ce soit dans la nature
humaine profonde en tout cas pas dans la
mienne et pas dans un cell que je vois
autour de moi
il faut juste
je peux compléter quand même par rapport
aussi c'était aussi de vos questions
monsieur le Président sur le
la façon dont nos actions étaient
pénalement traitées et
donc actuellement il y a plusieurs
dizaines de personnes qui ont été ou qui
vont être en procès et c'est des
personnes
comme Pierre comme Bertrand comme moi
qui n'ont jamais été au tribunal
correctionnel pour quelqu'un fraction
que ce soit et
voilà si je vais parler pour ma part je
peux pas parler pour les autres mais je
suis à l'image de plein de gens qui ont
un boulot qui ont des enfants qui ont
une famille qui ont des activités qui
ont autre chose à faire
et ça rejoint ce que disait pierre c'est
à dire que si on est prêt à continuer
malgré
cette menace et et ses procès et c'est
condamnations qu'on a c'est bien parce
que l'enjeu derrière il concerne notre
existence et il concerne aussi nos
valeurs comment continuer à
regarder mes enfants dans les yeux à
faire mon boulot de médecin à l'hôpital
qui protège les plus vulnérables tout en
sachant qu'en fait
les plus vulnérables vont mourir de la
chaleur en France et déjà cet été
donc
face à ça on ne peut pas on ne peut pas
s'arrêter quand on quand on prend
conscience au-delà de son travail
quotidien ce que j'ai fait il y a
quelques temps
quand on prend conscience de la réelle
gravité et de liminant de ce péril
et qu'on ne peut plus revenir en arrière
et on se dit si je ne fais rien je
cautionne c'est immobilisme c'est une
action de l'État condamné deux fois
donc voilà on est des citoyens qui
prenons nos responsabilités et je
reviens sur la question de nos rapports
aux institutions on demande à ce que on
espère que les les personnes qu'on
rencontre dans les institutions y
compris l'institution judiciaire vont
prendre leur responsabilité de citoyens
pour
aller dans le sens de la préservation de
de nos vies de notre climat de l'eau de
nos récoltes et pas criminaliser et pas
condamné ce qui les défendent
monsieur taverne et puis ensuite
monsieur belametti
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur madame messieurs alors tout
d'abord je voudrais quand même répondre
à notre collègue Lucas on vous a pas vu
depuis le début des travaux en
commission d'enquête donc vos réflexions
d'or on en a parlé pendant des heures
donc si vous aviez assisté au débat dans
son nom pas là donc moi c'est c'est une
petite question que je ne vous ai pas
interrompu
[Musique]
j'ai insulté personne personne jusqu'à
prendre du contraire
vous avez évoqué des conflits armés etc
dans vos propos introductifs
donc moi je voudrais savoir quel est
votre position quand des individus
viennent sur une manifestation interdite
avec des armes
qui plus est des armes destinées à
donner la mort
par rapport aux policiers aux gendarmes
etc il y a eu des gendarmes grièvement
blessés donc je voudrais savoir quel est
votre position par rapport à ça ensuite
monsieur le rapporteur l'a évoqué vous
avez cité notamment des violences venant
de l'extrême droite nous nous condamnons
toutes les violences d'où qu'elles
viennent extrême droite extrême gauche
également et d'ailleurs selon les
dernières auditions on peut dire que
l'ultra gauche plutôt majoritaire
donc je voudrais savoir ce que vous
véhiculez un message politique ou alors
à ce que vous défendez vraiment votre
cause
ensuite vous parlez de maintien de
l'ordre
est-ce que c'est vraiment également
votre
but de parler de maintien de l'ordre à
la française je vous invite juste parce
que vous parlez de répression etc
d'aller dans des pays étrangers
aller en Afrique centrale aller dans les
pays du Moyen-Orient allez voir là-bas
comment ça se passe et ensuite vous
pourrez venir faire des des commentaires
en France
ensuite vous avez parlé de et c'est ça
qui est quand même important de de
personnes tabassées en garde à vue nous
avons auditionné madame Simoneau qui est
quand même la contre général des lieux
de prévention liberté à aucun moment
elle parle de Jean tabassés elle parle
plutôt de de conditions de garde à vue
aussi bien pour les personnes placé en
garde à vue que pour les policiers
eux-mêmes
donc je voudrais savoir est-ce que
aujourd'hui
puisque même si effectivement le
réchauffement climatique est un sujet
important je le reconnais bien
volontiers mais la France est quand même
un des pays les plus vers au monde moi
je suis élu dans une dans une
circonscription à 90% rurale 90% rural
il y a des élus locaux qui prennent des
mesures pour effectivement essayer de
limiter la consommation énergétique il y
a des exploitants agricoles qui essaient
de faire du mieux possible véritablement
pour préserver l'environnement et malgré
cela nous avons dans ma circonscription
des actions qui peuvent être souvent
violentes
par rapport justement aux décisions qui
sont prises donc est-ce que vous pensez
qu'il faudrait plutôt continuer
vos actions
ou alors est-ce que vous êtes là pour
faire passer un message politique parce
que vous mélangez violence
maintient de l'ordre en fait là vous
passez un message politique donc je dois
savoir quel est véritablement votre
position et la position de votre de
votre mouvement par rapport à cela merci
je vous laisse décider de qui répond
du coup sur la je vais pas répondre à
toutes les questions parce qu'il y en
avait beaucoup je vais en répondre à une
ou deux et après je passerai la parole
sur les personnes venant avec des armes
je vais même pas répondre parce que je
pense qu'on a dit à peu près 15 fois
depuis le début de cette commission
qu'on était non violent donc je vais
refaire la même réponse nous sommes non
violent
sur la politique de maintien de l'ordre
en France sur le fait qu'on a de la
chance moi j'ai envie de vous demander
si vous êtes déjà allé en garde à vue si
vous avez déjà été incarcéré pour des
actions non violentes je pense que ce
n'est pas le cas
non une incarcération c'est quand on est
privé de liberté c'est quelqu'un en
garde à vue en tout cas moi c'est comme
ça que je l'ai vécu donc là dessus je
pense qu'on parle à un niveau
d'information qui est tellement
différent que pareil je vois pas
l'intérêt spécialement à répondre
effectivement les
comment
non mais du coup vu qu'il m'a été
vu qu'il nous a été expliqué que c'était
pas grand chose et qu'il fallait s'en
satisfaire parce qu'il y avait pire
ailleurs je me permets de répondre que
c'est par l'expérience voilà
si les personnes avec qui ont perdu un
œil une main dans des manifestations
vous semble ok c'est votre droit ce
n'est pas mon cas et sur la partie et
sur la partie peut-être sur les pays
verts
[Musique]
juste je rebondis quand même sur la
partie vous parliez des vous disiez oui
aller manifester en Afrique centrale
enfin je sais je sais pas exactement ce
que vous aviez dit exactement mais le je
sais plus exactement ce que vous avez
dit mais vous vous disiez les conditions
de répression sont pires dans d'autres
pays oui c'est le cas et alors c'est pas
pour autant qu'il y a pire ailleurs que
c'est bien ce qu'on fait ce qu'on fait
ici enfin faut si on se compare toujours
au pire effectivement on se sent
toujours bien et dans et dans le mais
non mais c'est exactement la même chose
en plus d'ailleurs sur sur parce que
vous non mais vous employez le même
genre d'argument vous dites la France
est un des pays le plus vierge les plus
verts au monde donc là encore vous
faites une comparaison par le négatif en
allant chercher les pires pays
industriels et en comparant avec la
France pour dire mais regardez nous par
rapport à eux on est on est quand même
beaucoup plus avancé sauf que en France
il se trouve que on est actuellement à
une moyenne de 10 tonnes d'émissions de
CO2 par habitant 10 tonnes d'émission de
CO2 par habitant si on compte les
émissions à porter
on sait que si on veut respecter les
accords de Paris donc si on veut avoir
une chance de nous faire notre part pour
rester dans un monde à peu près viable
il faut qu'on passe à deux tonnes de CO2
par habitant alors c'est 10 tonnes de
évidemment il y a des disparités très
grandes au sein de la population
généralement les populations les plus
riches vont avoir tendance à émettre
davantage que les autres donc c'est
aussi quelque chose qu'il faut regarder
de près mais globalement non la France
n'est pas un des ça n'a aucun sens de
dire la France est l'un des pays les
plus verts au monde nous nous sommes
citoyens français nous estimons que la
France ne fait pas sa part ne fait
d'autant plus pas sa part si on
considère la responsabilité historique
que la France a et le niveau d'émission
qu'elle a les émissions qu'elle a pu
émettre sur toute son histoire
industrielle donc non nous ne partageons
pas du tout ce point de vue
nos propos
par rapport à
le maintien de l'ordre
je vais passer la parole à Monsieur
bellamity
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur chers collègues je veux dire
messieurs et Madame que vous n'êtes pas
sur le bon des accusés au moment je n'ai
eu cet état d'esprit en rejoignant cette
salle de commission et vous dire que
contrairement à ce qui est inscrit sur
votre compte Instagram qui faisait tas
de la convocation à laquelle vous avez
répondu favorablement parler de de
signal inquiétant pour la démocratie au
contraire je crois que votre présence
ici nous permet de mieux comprendre
votre spécificité vos spécificités vos
modes d'action par rapport à d'autres
qui peuvent être qualifiés de violon qui
sont violents manifestement afin de
mieux les différer vous parliez tout à
l'heure de victoire politique
significative de l'action non violente
si un moment donné on veut obtenir des
victoires politiques de vos actions en
tout cas de celles que vous revendiquez
il faut qu'on se parle et quoi de mieux
que le faire ici devant la
représentation nationale donc votre
présence ici mais en aucun cas un signe
de malaise démocratique bien au
contraire j'aurais quatre du coup
interrogations pour mieux comprendre vos
actions ce que vous représentez les
différences qui vous caractérisent par
rapport à d'autres organisations
vous réalisez semble-t-il mais vous me
corrigerez si je me trompe des blocages
de circulation des actions comme comme
celle-ci qui sont manifestement
illégales quelle est la différence selon
vous entre l'illégalité et la
non-violence est-ce qu'une action non
violente de fait devrait être
légitime au sens de légal c'est ma
première question et le cours l'air
cette question c'est comment espérer
vous convaincre un maximum de Françaises
et Français qui infinie se traduisent
par des votes dans les urnes en
démocratie
en menant de telles actions comment vous
vous souhaitez susciter l'adhésion en
menant des actions qui perturbent le
quotidien des Françaises et Français
deuxième question vous parlez dans votre
même poste Instagram
désolé de la terre en tout cas des
actions qui ont mené à leur dissolution
est-ce que vous sentez solidaire des
actions de dégradation des exploitations
agricoles qui ont été menées dans le
département dont je suis le représentant
en l'occurrence la Loire-Atlantique
et où les condamnez-vous
le cas échéant je parle évidemment des
dégradations des exploitations agricoles
troisième question vous parlez dans ce
même poste Instagram qui est long et
j'invite tout à chacun à aller le lire
des livres politiques et économiques qui
organiseraient sciemment
l'anéantissement du vivant il faut
savoir de qui vous parlez peut-être que
l'inclure dans cette élite politique
mais j'aimerais que vous précisiez de
qui vous parliez et enfin
est-ce que vous envisagez ce que vous
projetez de mener des actions ailleurs
qu'en France j'entends par là des pays
qui sont les principaux émetteurs de gaz
à effet de serre je vous remercie
et vous repassez la parole
oui alors je vais essayer de répondre à
certaines questions et
camarades répondront aux besoins
alors déjà sur les votre question sur
les blocages de la circulation je vous
avoue j'ai pas super bien pas très très
bien compris la question
vous vous demandez si
c'est la différence entre l'égal
légitime enfin je vous avoue j'ai pas
très bien compris la question mais en
gros nos actions de blocage de
circulation c'est des actions qui
existent depuis très longtemps ça a été
d'ailleurs évoqué il y a d'autres
mouvements qui l'ont fait avant nous de
manière générale des actions de blocage
bon bah il y a d'autres organisations
qui les pratiquent que ce soit les
syndicats depuis le début de l'ère
industrielle les syndicats pratiquent ce
type de ce type d'action donc et il est
effectivement il fut un temps où c'était
illégal pour les syndicats c'était même
plus d'un temps illégal 2 ce syndiqué
puis il a été illégal d'organiser des
grèves d'organiser des blocages
industriels et progressivement ses
droits ont été acquis aujourd'hui pour
le moment effectivement il y a aucun
dispositif légal qui permet de
reconnaître la légitimité de nos actions
comme par exemple il en existe pour les
lanceurs d'alerte qui il y a 10 ans ou
plus n'était pas non plus autorisé à
pratiquer leurs actions de lanceur
d'alerte mais aujourd'hui il y a un
droit qui conforte et qui protège les
lanceurs d'alerte et qui légitime leur
action donc aujourd'hui c'est vrai que
nos actions elle sort de la légalité et
il y a pas encore de dispositif légal ou
juridique qui vient valider la
légitimité de ces actions je sais pas si
je réponds bien à votre question mais en
tout cas c'est c'est après vous pourrez
éventuellement clarifier s'il y avait
autre chose que vous vouliez sur lequel
vous vouliez nous interroger ensuite par
rapport au soulèvement de la Terre nous
de manière générale nous sommes
solidaire de l'ensemble des mouvements
qui manifestent de manière non violente
au sens au sens du droit français
c'est-à-dire non violente à l'égard des
personnes nous sommes solidaires de
toutes les personnes qui d'une manière
ou d'une autre vont engager des luttes
de résistance pour préserver le vivant
après nous c'est pas nous les actions de
dégradation ou autre c'est pas les
actions qu'on a choisies nous c'est pas
les actions qu'on a choisies donc on
choisit déjà différemment donc
maintenant donc ce serait difficile de
juste nous assimiler tel quel mais de
fait nous partageons de fait nous
partageons la même nous nous partageons
une même une même volonté de préserver
le vivant
ensuite sur les élites politiques et
économiques encore une fois c'est une
question de connaissance il y a 20 30 40
50 ans
il y avait encore beaucoup de monde qui
était pas bien on va dire
sensibiliser à ces questions qui avaient
pas forcément lu les rapports du GIEC et
pas forcément étudier la littérature
scientifique sur le sujet du
réchauffement climatique donc à cette
époque là on pouvait dire effectivement
les élites politiques et économiques
font tourner un système sans
connaissance de cause en tout cas on
pouvait leur accorder la légitime le
bénéfice du doute bien que on se soit
rendu compte que par exemple une
entreprise comme celle de Total à
sciemment caché des preuves des études
scientifiques qui démontré que leur
activité était néfastes pour le climat
et ce il y a plus de 40 ans en arrière
donc en réalité ça dépend pour qui mais
aujourd'hui clairement on va pas se
cacher derrière son ignance dire les
rapports du GIEC tout le monde tout le
monde enfin je dirais tout le monde a lu
des articles au moins scientifiques qui
ument leurs propos donc oui les
personnes qui aujourd'hui sont au
pouvoir les élites politiques ou
économiques ça ce qu'elles font elles
savent les conséquences qu'impliquent de
maintenir un système tel que celui tel
que celui de sur lequel s'appuie notre
société aujourd'hui
simplement
pour peut-être juste compléter parce que
je trouvais que la réponse était
complète mais un élément c'est sur la
question de la légalité légitimité je
pense qu'il y a plusieurs choses qui
sont appréciées là dedans notamment
est-ce qu'il existe d'autres manières
d'agir qui soit elle légale et qu'il
soit proportionnée et je pense que le
principal terme à retenir de ça c'est la
proportionnalité de l'action aujourd'hui
on estime que bloquer une route pour
alerter et perturber pour déclencher une
action politique sur le réchauffement
climatique c'est proportionné vis-à-vis
de la catastrophe qui menace la vie sur
terre c'est proportionné et d'ailleurs
ça a été reconnu par un juge
partiellement qui n'a pas reconnu
totalement l'état de nécessité car par
contre prononcer une dispense de peine
parce qu'il reconnaissait le la
proportionnalité de l'action
c'est un janvier dernier
merci beaucoup pour ces éléments je vais
passer la parole à Monsieur le
Rapporteur simplement avant de lui
repasser la parole quand on regarde un
petit peu les le en tout cas les
arguments que que vous développez dans
vos écrits dans vos sur les réseaux
sociaux il y en a un où on peut lire
l'objectif est de catalyser des
soulèvements populaires massifs dans les
années à venir
qu'est-ce que vous entendez par là
oui
très simplement ça a déjà un petit peu
été évoqué mais
le GIEC lui-même déclare dans une large
mesure la société civile et la seule
force motrice sur laquelle on puisse
compter pour pousser les institutions à
changer au rythme voulu donc il y a des
changements d'ampleur qui sont face à
nous des changements d'ampleur donc
nécessairement ces changements doivent
s'accompagner de mobilisation sociale
d'ampleur sinon il ne se feront pas
c'est déjà été évoqué il y a des
pressions économiques d'un côté si de
l'autre côté on n'a pas une pression
populaire une pression d'un mouvement
social d'ampleur bah écoutez ça on a on
y arrivera pas donc effectivement nous
notre objectif initial
nos actions n'ont pas enfin pour but de
mobiliser dans un premier temps les
personnes les plus les plus motivées on
va dire les plus conscientisés mais
l'objectif à terme c'est de mobiliser
bien plus rare bien plus largement
autour de nous
je vous remercie et je repasse la parole
peut-être simplement
être complémentaire de ça pour
comprendre pourquoi on a choisi la
rénovation thermique des bâtiments
spécifiquement et c'est en miroir avec
l'objectif de catalyser des soulèvements
populaires c'est parce que c'est la
mesure la plus simple la plus gagnable
et la plus consensuelle dans la société
qui fait à la fois consensus dans les
classes sociales les plus pauvres les
plus aisés où il y a globalement
quasiment personne qui est opposé et du
coup c'est extrêmement important de
comprendre que si le gouvernement et les
personnes au pouvoir ne sont même pas
capables de faire avancer le sujet de la
rénovation qui est vraiment la première
marche la marche la plus simple sur
laquelle monter pour déclencher une
action c'est vraiment qu'on ne peut pas
nourrir d'espoir sincère et sérieux
vis-à-vis que cette vis-à-vis de cette
action politique
oui merci monsieur le Président d'abord
je redis à nos collègues qui ont posé la
question sur la confusion des gens et
l'intérêt de cette audition que c'est
précisément parce que vous avez choisi
l'action non violente et parce que nous
regardons les groupes muscules violents
dont vous n'êtes pas que nous souhaitons
avoir votre point de vue sur le rejet
d'une méthode d'action qui n'est pas la
vôtre je crois que c'est assez clair de
la même façon que vous avez interroger
des personnes qui ne sont pas violents
et qui par contre ont un jugement
l'interprétation une vision de ce qu'est
la violence dans notre société et ce
qu'est la violence politique et comment
elle se définit je reviens sur la
question de notre collègue il y a
quelques instants
lorsque des agissements cette fois-ci
violents contre des personnes
sont commis et nous n'avons pas accès au
dossier de la dissolution des
soulèvements de la terre mais le juge
administratif le Conseil d'État il y
aura accès bien sûr ce qui sera il a été
saisi lorsque des actions violentes
contre des personnes sont commises par
je ne sais pas comment les nommer
d'ailleurs activistes militants je serai
très prudent sur la façon de les
qualifier sont commises à l'encontre de
personnes est-ce que vous vous sentez
solidaire ou par principe vous
considérez que ce n'est pas acceptable
parce que j'ai bien compris la réponse
de Bertrand canta giron il y a quelques
instants solidarité vis-à-vis de celles
et ceux qui viennent des combats communs
sur la question environnementale j'ai
bien compris mais j'imagine que cette
solidarité s'arrête à la violence y
compris dans ce qu'elle est commise au
nom de cette cause c'est une question
que je voulais vous poser
j'ai l'impression que je vous ai déjà
répondu excusez-moi monsieur le
rapporteur
en tant que en tant que voilà Florence
Marshall citoyenne
impliquées dans dans ma vie mon pays ma
famille mon métier
quand je vois ce qui se passe à
Sainte-Souline
je suis choquée et ce qui me choque
c'est pas la violence dont vous parlez
c'est les 6000 grenades qui ont été
tirés et elles ont pas été tirés par les
mini festins les 6000 grenades c'est ça
qui me choque on parle de
proportionnalité
c'est ça qui me choque c'est c'est
les gens qui sont envoyés dans le coma
alors qu'ils ont une autre vie et qui
sont pas des Black Blocs donc enfin je
vous ai déjà répondu de cette façon là
pardon
souligne il y avait à peu près 8000
personnes donc 1000 personnes dans une
logique de radicalité et sur les
chiffres qu'on nous donne et 250 dans
une logique de violence aux personnes
quand une personne se rend une
manifestation
à ce moment là les grenades ne sont pas
lancés avec des boules de pétanque ou
des armes par destination quel est votre
réaction j'entends bien ce que vous
dites sur le problème de l'escalade de
la désescalade sur le maintien de
l'ordre qui est un débat qu'on a
également bien sûr et d'ailleurs j'ai
souhaité je le rappelle que notre
commission porte sur le déroulement de
l'ensemble des manifestations et
rassemblement y compris la question du
21 novembre ça ne soit pas zappé de
notre réflexion au contraire mais quand
vous apprenez que des individus au nom
de la cause environnementale viennent
avec des armes par destination vous
confirmez par conséquent votre rejet de
cette action
oui c'est un problème mais la
culpabilité n'est pas de ce côté là la
culpabilité est dans je vais pas refaire
le propos liminaire mais et dans le fait
que l'action politique n'offre aucun
espoir la lutte non violente n'est
absolument pas écoutée pour l'instant
donc effectivement c'est un problème
grave
mais par contre il faut remettre la cuve
la culpabilité au bon endroit
vous comment pardon vous vous commencez
votre question en parlant de ces
manifestants cette manifestation marquée
par la radicalité
oui mais moi je pense qu'on ne peut pas
déconnecter le motif de ces milliers de
personnes qui étaient présents
et
la question de ce qui s'est passé il y a
quand même eu une répression
qui a été au-delà
des personnes que je connais pas j'y
étais pas je ne sais pas je suis pas
enquêteuse mais il y a une répression
qui est allée au delà moi c'est ce que
je vois et je vois surtout qu'on en fait
un récit
différents selon qu'on est du côté
des forces de l'ordre ou selon que on
était une mère de famille des sur place
c'est pas le même récit et c'est ça qui
me choque beaucoup et
moi je ne me pose la question est-ce que
cette commission d'enquête parlementaire
va éclaircir ce récit et
on peut pas déconnecter ça du fait que
les bassines dont il est question
elle profite à 6% des agriculteurs aux
agro-industriels
et
dernier point
vous nous interrogez sur
sur cette question qui a quand même en
lien avec cette histoire de
d'autorisation ou pas de bassines donc
là il y a une manifestation
contre
l'installation et l'utilisation des
mégas bassines avec un dispositif
policier sans précédent et je suis pas
sûr je sais pas si dans vos travaux vous
avez
évoqué quelque chose qui s'est passé
dans la période qui correspond à cette
commission qui était une agression
en fin de manifestation de la FNSEA
contre le domicile d'un responsable
écologique c'était le 22 mars et c'était
une manifestation de la FNSEA parce que
la juridiction le le
tribunal en question avait interdit les
bassines donc il faut et là il a pas été
question de dispositif policier de cette
sorte donc voilà il y a quand même
différents poids différentes mesures qui
moi me questionne et m'inquiète
profondément en tant que voilà vos
tentes citoyennes
présente ici ma démarche a juste de deux
points qui me semblent quand même
important de préciser en tant que
président de cette commission d'enquête
d'abord sur ce que vous évoquez ce point
a été clairement mentionné avec les
représentants de du syndicat
d'exploitant agricoles et ils nous ont
clairement indiqué que il
ne en tout cas qu'il se désolidariser de
tout type d'action de ce type là et que
comme vous vous avez pu dire que vous
êtes sur des actions non violentes ils
ont précisément tenu à insister qu'ils
étaient sur cette ligne là et d'ailleurs
vous pourrez comment dire comme vous
c'était une audition publique vous
pouvez la consulter en fait par rapport
à ce que ce que vous dites évidemment il
y a des récits et on les entend et notre
rôle est effectivement de faire en sorte
que nous puissions entendre les récits
mais
le rôle d'une commission d'enquête c'est
par de la les récits arriver à aller
vers du factuel et vers une
objectivation entre guillemets du réel
et c'est ça notre rôle en tant que
commission d'enquête parce que c'est une
commission d'enquête qui évidemment les
parce que dès que l'on dirait si il peut
y avoir à la fois interprétation et
narration notre rôle est justement
d'aller par de la les récits aller
chercher le factuel voilà et c'est ça
qui doit nous motiver pour arriver à
objectiver et de voir en fonction de
cela évidemment ce qui le convient de
faire je vais juste repasser la parole à
Monsieur Lucas ce sera la dernière
intervention puisque nous avons un petit
peu glissé en termes de temps et donc
vous permettre éventuellement de réagir
oui bah dans le prolongement à ce
moment-là oui allez-y merci monsieur le
Président rapidement parce que je suis
assez surpris de la dernière question du
rapporteur on a et vous avez dit
vous-même nous avons convoqué vous avez
convoqué dernière rénovation parce que
pour éclairer sur un mode d'action non
violent et vous demandez à plusieurs
reprises les personnes qui sont là
est-ce que vous condamnez telle action
violente sur un événement qui vous
disent que eux ont une action non
violente je crois qu'on voit là un peu
clair dans votre jeu on l'avait dit au
moment où on discutait de cette
commission d'enquête en séance dans la
volonté de criminaliser finalement le
mouvement écologiste et moi je crois je
ne suis pas d'accord avec Manuel Valls
dont vous avez été proche je ne sais pas
si tu es encore le cas quand il disait
expliqué c'est excuser quand on vous
explique comment naît la violence dans
la société vous vous répondez de suite
mais est-ce que vous condamnez est-ce
que nous allons passer chaque audition a
interrogé chaque personne qui est
interrogée sur toutes les violences qui
existent dans la société qui ont de près
ou de loin un rapport avec la cause
qu'il défendent dans ce cas-là
interroger moins moi je suis militant de
gauche sur toutes les violences commises
dans le cadre de rassemblement sociaux
républicains démocratiques depuis 200
ans et pas son zizi des heures entières
je crois là que nous débordons du cadre
de cette commission d'en et je ne vois
pas au nom de quoi on demande à des
personnes individuellement de répondre à
ce qu'elle condamne telle ou telle
action moi je ne vous demande pas si
vous condamnez telle ou telle action et
vous n'avez pas à me demander non plus
si je suis quand même tel ou telle
action je pense qu'il faut là aussi
qu'on fasse attention pour un petit
récit médiatique que vous voulez
installer dans l'opinion à l'égard des
mouvements écologistes à ne pas faire de
cette commission d'enquête n'importe
quoi alors rassurez-vous il n'y a pas
d'objectif je dirais de procéder
d'attention alors par contre je note
dans votre propos que vous vous
souhaiteriez être témoin dans la
commission d'enquête on peut le faire je
peux on peut on peut on peut
éventuellement le faire si vous le
souhaitez mais monsieur Caron je vous en
prie je prolongeais le propos de mon
collègue je suis plus étonné c'est aussi
je suis vraiment choqué de votre part
mais sur la porteur d'autant que je sais
maintenant que c'est pas votre
inconscient qui parle mais bien votre
conscience lorsque vous tentez de faire
dire des choses à nos à nos témoins du
jour qui n'ont aucun lien avec l'objet
de cette commission d'enquête on a
absolument pas leur demander comment il
se positionne par un mouvement dont il
se déclare eux-mêmes complètement
étranger je ne vois absolument pas
rapport ou alors c'est tenter de jeter
l'eau propre de tenter un doute pour
ceux qui suivent ses débats en disant
vous voyez finalement tous les
mouvements écologistes ont une forme
comme ça nébuleuse de manque de clarté
par rapport à la question de la violence
et je pense que là effectivement il y a
quelque chose de dangereux dans ce que
nous sommes en train de faire enfin vous
pas nous pas mon collègue et moi sur ça
je tiens vraiment à insister pour que
figure dans le rapport et je ne doute
pas de votre honnêteté pour bien le
faire figurer sur cette clarification
qui a été faite ce soir effectivement ça
c'est un débrie de cette audition de la
différence qui existe entre la violence
et une dégradation je crois que là il y
a une confusion qui est en train d'être
installée et je pense que le rapport
aura au moins le mérite justement de
clarifier cette chose vous pouvez me le
confirmer monsieur le rapporteur
un rapport est pas rédigé à ce stade
donc non mais peut-être s'engager
justement à bien claquer les choses et
aussi nous garantir que non cette
commission n'a pas pour objet de jeter
le doute sur tous les mouvements
écologistes aujourd'hui dans ce pays
surtout à ce moment ça a été rappelé en
début d'auditions nous n'avons constaté
qu'il y avait une dissolution d'un de
ces mouvements dans des circonstances
qui nous gêne terriblement monsieur
Caron vous savez
votre propos est très intéressant
puisque la réponse est dans votre dans
votre propos vous imaginez bien que
c'est pas l'objectif enfin on est on est
dans une commission d'enquête Assemblée
nationale qui va donner lieu enfin le
rapport donnera lieu à un débat
préalable aussi avec la possibilité pour
chaque groupe parlementaire de pouvoir
adjoindre au rapport sa propre vision de
tout cela donc vous savez pertinemment
que ce que vous êtes en train de dire
enfin le le prochain intention que que
vous vous tentez vous savez qu'il n'a
pas lieu d'être c'est la crédibilité
même de notre institution qui est en jeu
et vous le savez
réaction de partager de mon côté
je vais passer à part monsieur le
rapporteur
je veux bien qu'on polémique inutilement
simplement précisément parce que la
structure qui est avec nous aujourd'hui
on est édition a choisi la non-violence
je le redis ça m'intéresse en tant que
rapporteur de connaître où sont les
frontières d'action je sais ce que la
frontière d'action d'un parti politique
je sais ce qui est la frontière d'action
d'une structuration associative en
général je sais ce qui est la frontière
d'action d'un syndicat je sais qu'elle
est la frontière d'action de dernière
innovation parce qu'ils l'ont explicité
et là où Monsieur kata giron a dit à un
moment donné nous sommes bien évidemment
solidaires des actions menées par des
structures telles que sous le nom de la
terre je souhaitais qu'il confirme à
l'exception bien sûr des actions
violentes c'est inutile de me répondre
et il me semble que ma question était ma
question était légitime parce qu'elle a
permis de lever une ambiguïté qui aurait
pu être interprété des propos qui
avaient été tenus à l'instant même sur
la question des soulèvements de la terre
donc pas de procès d'intention vous
verrez mon rapport sera très clair je
ferai des explicitations de tout les
sujets qui sont très nébuleux dans le
débats démocratique ce sera le rôle du
rapport en particulier non violence
violence j'essaierai même d'expliciter
comment on peut définir la radicalité en
politique où sont les frontières
j'essaierai de le faire honnêtement
voilà j'essaierai d'expliciter aussi la
frontière entre provocation légitimation
incitation et ça sera pas simple et si
c'est pas simple je le dirai et je
dirais que il est peut-être d'ailleurs
difficile de tracer des frontières de ce
point de vue voilà comment j'essaie de
travailler mon cher collègue député il
me semble en posant la question en effet
de façon insistante j'ai permis à la
structure de clarifier ce qui avait été
dit quelques instants auparavant dans la
relation aux actions menées par le
soulevé de la terre
très bien en tout cas
il nous reste à vous remercier donc
aussi bien Madame Marchal que Monsieur
Taieb que Monsieur
calta giron donc merci pour votre votre
présence et l'échange que nous avons pu
avoir